go to bigheadsmedia.com for more great
podcasts
welcome to dig on america where we speak
truth to power every week we give you
the date on how american history
policies and media created the social
and political issues we face today
doa is independent media supported by
listeners but they'll tell you we're
just fake news deep state propaganda
funded by george soros the clinton
foundation blm marxists and
montana burns
um
eddie van halen
that's good
obviously
as always eddie van halen so welcome to
everybody to dig on america this is
jason dutch i am here with mikey
feminie
and my
five-year-old son who is
this close to me right now because mom's
gonna work me oh he can't see there he
is he's right there because mom's in a
work meeting so
he might decide to join the show
because he could give a rat's rear end
that i'm podcasting right now but i have
to be a dad and i have to do this show
because you demand it uh mikey how you
doing today brother
um i did a lot of nothing today and it
felt great
i haven't done nothing in a long time
but it was nice to just um
vacuum the living room
i have hardwood floors so it was one mat
and smoke weed all day
it was amazing i highly recommend it um
if wheat is legal in your state just
spend one day a year
doing one thing only it's nice
i i didn't know you smoked it i thought
you just ate the edibles
well i've transitioned because uh the
edibles are really [ __ ] strong you're
on the you're on the pathway to cocaine
yeah
i could i'm already talking to a couple
of meth dealers i'm trying to figure out
who who's lowballing me you're going to
get your biden biting crack pipe are you
going to get your biden crack pipe
hell yeah
but it's funny because like i
uh work a stressful job in a stressful
industry in a stressful town during
stressful times
and i quit smoking cigarettes so i was
just staying stressed you know having an
edible was really fun until i felt like
my k my chest was caving in so a couple
of a couple of hits and i can [ __ ]
just relax for an hour and be perfectly
fine so
it's not evil guys it helps with anxiety
and stress so
i'm a lot calmer than i normally am as
as
a lot calmer sure you are
you're as angry as ever uh
angry black man so as you heard uh
as you heard um we have some guests on
the show with us today big hospital join
us at some point
your guest is as good as mine
uh but with us today uh to my let's see
here this way uh we have
the amazing uh podcaster and youtuber
actually no this guy's not amazing he's
just a podcaster and youtuber now a
friend of ours from twitter tony
michaels thank you for having me thank
you for the tony michaels show and what
and you call your twitter show something
no no no it's not so exciting i can't
remember what it is we do two hours a
day every single weekday and we do that
we it used to be we did a twitch stream
the [ __ ] list roundup the shitload i was
i was thinking shut the [ __ ] up with
tony michaels well yeah well it's [ __ ]
them you know and then that's my that's
my um you know my phrase i guess like i
it wasn't intentional to to capture that
that trademark i guess but uh i just say
[ __ ] them all the time so i kind of
stuck i think with the audience but no
we do the [ __ ] list roundup we go
through the tweety tweets and the trendy
trends every single every single day i
used to do it just as a live stream and
then it became part of the podcast so uh
people liked it i you know i got it i
got the idea for my son he watches he
watches video games on youtube while
he's playing video games
oh [ __ ] i thought maybe maybe people
will watch me surf twitter while they're
serving twitter i didn't think it was
possible but they they do it
and
it always irritates me when i'm i'm like
here we are you probably like the same
thing you know we're trying to do some
social change get a few hundred watches
some jackass plays among us and get 16
million views some girl licks the ear an
ear-shaped microphone and gets 45 treats
do not [ __ ] understand it it's not
it's how is that how is that profitable
well you know how is that profitable
humans are garbage you know
i have here
an ear-shaped microphone everyone no
don't you [ __ ] do it don't you play
so so technical difficulties guys we
just lost the dutch hopefully
there he is there he is
the show's over i just soros soros seen
you licking the microphone like nope
nope nope nope can't do that can't do
that i i will let uh mikey
introduce his saint louis alum
ladies and gentlemen
ray reid
so ray tell us about you
hey guys so i'm ray reid i am running
for congress in missouri's second
congressional district it's the suburbs
of saint louis missouri right next to
congressman corey bush
yeah y'all and you said you're out of
brentwood
i am born and raised in brentwood um i'm
the candidate in this race who's
actually from st louis um
yeah grew up here went to college at the
university of central missouri in
warrensburg uh worked for our last uh
mules the mules the muse
oh yeah i'm outnumbered here three to
one by missourians
yeah so so what's your what's your
opinion on kirkwood and why it's better
than uh brentwood
so
[Laughter]
that is such a deep cut no one will
understand the brentwood kirkwood
rivalry unless you've been there
yeah yeah it's only second to the
webster kirkwood
uh st louis humor
it's only funny for like eighteen people
only
i was gonna say yeah because we all just
get either stuck there or all we do is
leave and talk about there every
listener to the show is like huh
okay but let's get to our so we play a
game we'll play i'll tell you what we'll
do if it's all right with mikey we'll
play the game because this is rey's
episode the first hour show we're gonna
talk about race candidacy um so we'll
start with playing the game with him and
then the second hour maybe we'll play it
we'll play with the game with tony so uh
we start out the show with a game called
the four down territory we will ask you
four questions
you will give us four answers these are
non-political 30-second answer is
perfectly fine um so let me call the
audible
18 19 27
missouri hut hut oh man i knew this guy
he's gonna mississippi river
mason dixon line
it happened we were all here when it
happened you were all here when it
happened so ray i will ask you if you
don't mind the first question
um when you were a kid
what was
your favorite saturday activity
oh
it's basketball um
yeah when i was a kid my same group of
friends that i had in middle school
carried on through high school and
college we all we all played basketball
we snuck in the countless rec centers
around around the district um eventually
they just gave us passes but um
it's back in grown-ups where you're
going in through the exit
pretty much yeah
okay so basketball mikey your turn sir
favorite 80s movie you only get one
ferris bueller's day off
good and so solid that's that's that's a
solid answer all right tony screw you
all right tony he gets to ask you a
question now tony ask him any question
you want i i i get to ask him a question
you absolutely do but just remember
he'll return the favor oh
i i i uh let's see i i wasn't prepared
for this but um exactly um
okay all right all right well ray what's
what's your what's your favorite
favorite 70s rock band i mean it will go
there
cool
70s rock
you might we went
huh
you might as well he's like
i mean i mean i hope i hope he does the
same to me
yeah i was born in 96 but the only
band that i know the only band that i
believe is a real band is the beatles
the greats of all time so
can i cop out with the beatles yeah i
mean they they you know i
they trickled into the 70s yeah i mean
it was it was it was lightly lightly i
will i allow it
well i mean i mean if ferris bueller's
day off is his answer for the uh the
best 80s movie i'll give him the beatles
ferris bueller is a good movie ray it's
a good movie it really is
but but tony wanted you to pick 16
candles no no no no no no no no no come
on come on come on now you gotta you
gotta
that that that's that's unfair i i i was
gonna go with back to the future i mean
that that's that's the movie i've never
actually seen back to the future what
all right no no no no no no you're not
visiting from this right right right
right you're running you're running
you're running for what cheating you've
never seen back then man you gotta let
me yeah
don't let these old fogies try to follow
oh [ __ ] listen i was born i was born in
87. i've seen back to the future huh
well mikey i was born in 85 what the
hell old fogies what the hell man you're
older
oh okay okay to me damn it and old
folkies as in anyone who likes uh back
to you it's okay
it's you like why because
come on you like it because it came out
when you were a kid it's not really that
good there's a lot of teenage ninja
turtles
is great but the second one is trash but
i love that no no no no no no no no no
easy on the easy on the second one's
trash stuff that's secret of the used
baby i mean that's where all the that's
where all the clowning cartoon
characters started um in in the in the
live action movies i mean
that bebop and rocksteady was the most
or
the no they're obnoxious
no it's not no i i'm gonna stand up for
that ray help me out here ray have you
seen the secret of the used movie
no here we go here we go oh damn oh
i'm on my head have you seen no so your
last question is
have you seen a movie
[Laughter]
i i have um we're actually catching up
me and my friends we're catching up on
movies that are like way before our time
so i'm just i just finished all the
harry potters we're starting star wars
next
um
he's doing his homework he's doing his
homework yeah yeah that was sort of an
illegal question you can skip back to
the future though
oh man
it's just all right dude damn right all
right man it's that that is the the 80s
movie that's it
like that's the one raiders of the lost
ark was the correct answer you all lost
indiana jones is way better than [ __ ]
back to the future
plot holes and everything all right ray
so if mikey if you would let's give race
center stage
uh give us uh ray if you will your
elevator pitch we want to know why
you're running for congress um
and um you know what your your campaign
is centered on please sir
yeah so
it's a kind of a crazy idea like a 25
year old kid challenging a 30-year
career uh republican and company
conference congresswoman anna wagner um
so i was born and raised here in st
louis i grew up here in brentwood went
to college in central missouri and
warrensburg
after my freshman year of college i got
a job in governor nixon's office working
on his policy team on working on bill
reviews and clemency applications and
got a little more than 70 folks pardoned
for non-violent drug offenses which is
really progressive for
the state of missouri like
with what we're doing right now um
so i was at 19 years old after nixon
went back to college working on campus
to fight sexual assaults on college
campuses all across the state of
missouri
post college got a job the state party
organizing for houston senate candidates
on mccaskill's 18 campaign
um
then just really saved the state party
in 2020 helping out with races in in the
uh 2020 cycle
um sat around with friends and just
thought about the issues that we cared
about and it's it's unions it's making
sure everyone gets health care it's
taking care of our environment
preserving our nation and preserving our
natural resources
um
and really there's this like fundamental
belief that i have is
i see the world through two separate
lens the world as it is and the world as
it should be and we really shall always
be fighting for the world as it should
be um
so what stood between me and and working
on those issues to make the world this
should be is this federal office it was
the closest in the country in 2020 uh
between donald trump and joe biden only
decided by 115 votes it's gonna look a
lot like it does now after redistricting
it's the best chance democrats have flip
a seat yeah
um so we're going to flip this thing
what are you doing to organize voters
out there
yeah so
my son is roaring at you so apparently
he wants
you want this he's very interested in
this answer so
um
so from day one i've always been about
building a broader coalition a new
coalition across divisions of race
region religion gender income and age
group um in this kind of district that's
what it's going to take to beat anne
wagner we have to bring folks together
um because i'm 25 years old we draw our
initial strength from young people so
i've been going around hitting high
schools and colleges all across the
state uh getting kids to sign up to
either knock doors make phone calls send
text messages if you live in the
district you're going to be here on
election day
we're getting plans to drive kids out
from their colleges here in the district
or make sure they vote absentee
um we're starting to see already is that
those kids are talking to their parents
and their grandparents about the kind of
world they want to grow up in so we're
really strengthening this campaign as
the days go by
um tony you got a question
yeah i do so so did you golf with jay
did you golf with him
i did not but we talked about a lot of
basketball the governor is a huge
basketball fan yeah he he is he is no uh
my brother golfs and he's golfed with uh
jay and his son so i didn't know if you
golfed with me or not i know that's not
political but i mean you know i might as
well ask you you said you went to um
warrensburg is that right yeah central
missouri yeah yeah the mules the meals
right mm-hmm what right
what are you talking about the gulf's
not political
what do you mean trump trump trump did
it 390 days of his presidency yeah it's
not political it's all that you know i
mean you can make it political if you
want but going on the golf course and
you know rubbing elbows with each other
then you know i guess i guess if you're
making back room deals and [ __ ] yeah
sure you know whatever are you are you
are you uh pushing copper russian copper
mod on lindsey graham yeah sure i mean
it's political whatever you want to say
[Laughter]
right right so so you say the seed is
flippable right
absolutely
so by a hundred and some votes is that
what you're saying
yeah and that's when we had our last can
this time uh in 2020 uh because of covet
they didn't really hold any public
events or really knock doors um like we
should we could have flipped this seat
last time we're gonna flip it
so
i mean do you think it was a messaging
problem but you just think it was that
enough people didn't know that they
could go yeah i think it's cheap
i think in missouri it's really about
personality because really in the state
of missouri
voters vote pretty progressively we just
passed medicaid expansion legal it's
medical marijuana um it's really about
the who who the candidate is on the
ballot and
it kind of takes a young energetic uh
kid who represents this district in more
ways than one we kind of breathe through
life into the missouri democratic party
and energize our base
you know i think you make a good point
about the you know a lot of states are
like missouri where they they have
progressive voters and those people
would vote progressively they just it's
got this mindset of these you know these
few issues whether it be um abortion or
something else they get they they get
locked into these these uh fights over
one issue or two issues or something and
then they get locked in this issue of
some of these progressive voters think
ah well you know it's it's it's a
shoe-in for the republican you know
there's a red state you know you hear
that [ __ ]
um which missouri has been
uh you know notorious for flipping back
and forth you know one way or the other
and it really wasn't until
um 2008 with the john mccain obama race
when missouri didn't actually vote for
the president of the united states which
was you know kind of surprising um
i mean i i don't think it surprises a
lot of people that are here in missouri
um you know but uh surpri kind of
surprised the country because um
missouri is a is a weird state it's been
a weird state all the way back before
the civil war so
you know
what would you say is the biggest
political topic to
missouri is it missourians or
missourians that uh
where where the right-wing government
does them the most disservice healthcare
or something like that
i mean they're wrong on just about every
issue but i'd say
the the one that does probably the most
disservice is yeah probably healthcare
you know our elected officials they say
that they'll take care of your health
care but their actions in in washington
my opponent in wagner her actions in
washington don't match her words here in
the district
um she's awful on health care
can you elaborate a little bit on what
awful means
yeah so she'll
around election time she'll say hey i'm
going to protect your pre-existing
conditions while at the same time during
a pandemic she's in court fighting to
strip people away from their health care
uh and in lawsuits against to chip away
obamacare
oh you don't say
yeah
that's missouri republicans really i
mean they talk out one side of their
mouth and the other side at the same
time you know i mean we have an attorney
general here who
um who's for you know oh well big
government's bad and he's the big bad
government telling local school
districts that they can't make sure that
their kids are healthy and safe in their
schools so [ __ ] that guy and uh you know
i mean uh it it it is it is the way of
uh missouri republicans a lot of times
to not give two shits about missourians
and uh that one more question rain that
i have is it missouri or is it missouri
is it
is it's azura right well yeah yeah
because because you you did work for jay
nixon so you definitely it is missouri
isn't it yeah i think
you're
since you were around jay that much you
had to say missouri right yeah well it
happens it's not like saying illinois
stop it stop it
people do that man just to irritate me
illa noise it's like stop stop and it's
not missouri either stop it the both of
you
know better
you know better you should do better
goddammit you should but they don't um
so
crt right when it comes to this whole
crt and schools thing ray do you hear
that a lot down there i'm guessing that
you do about this this pandering against
the the the evil ghost of crt the
phantom that's coming behind us to
destroy everything that we hold dear
what's your
what's your conversation with people on
that
um i kind of start off start off with
virginia i think the lesson one of the
last things in virginia was that we've
got to nominate candidates in the
democratic party who actually know how
to talk about race and are comfortable
talking about race um in in our in our
districts um
so as far as crt here like
you know they're a group of republicans
here who stir it up really just divide
people but
full disclaimer critical race theory is
not taught at the k-12 level um
yes it is what yes it is
fake news fake news
oh [ __ ]
there we go there was a teacher in san
diego who said she only had three years
to indoctrinate her kids so therefore
everyone yeah so like but what what is
it that you think should be focused on
as far as
um like do you have a plan or or a
suggestion for like you know the school
board members or people who are
advocating for for or against that
school board members where it's like
here you know this is what's appropriate
to learn at this age this is what's
appropriate to learn at this age and
then progressing to where you would
actually learn critical race theory by
the time you're 20. um do you have some
sort of
plan of progression as far as you know
teaching kids what they're
cognitively ready to learn
yeah so there's a great group here in
missouri um
moab
they pretty much
have uh their only goal is to
center our educational policy around
diversity equity and inclusion um
in our k-12 education system um so i've
pretty much been partnering with them to
help me develop my uh educational
platform for k-12 um
they're made up of
moms and districts and former teachers
uh and college students
um
but absolutely we want to develop a k-12
educational system uh centered around
diversity at quick inclusion
looks like we lost your your co-host
there mikey
good
now
i'm playing co-host i guess yes and now
that i have re i have finally completed
my coup to take over dig on america
well that was easy
you just kick him out of the room just
kick him out of the room
yeah and
let me click here ban for
life okay good good again okay um so
schools is always super big for me
because i've been bouncing back and
forth between like chicago suburbs and
downtown st louis my entire life
and boy the difference between the
school systems for like middle school
when i was going from
uh
uh uh
not bowling brook where was that i was
probably like carol stream so a little
bit out west and then moving back down
to st louis and it was just like
these kids are a year and a half behind
like we have done all of this so are
there any plans because i haven't really
been tapped in i've been up here for
about a decade now so are there any
plans or do you know of any um
groups i'm not looking for just like
like basic stuff but kind of like a
restructuring of how the school system
is set up in missouri because that's not
what it was pretty bad
yeah a lot of it's handled uh at the
state level with legislature um
as far as what i want to do in congress
is you know send as much money to state
and local governments as i can for uh
public education just like we stopped
sending all these money to since i was
absent all the money to charter schools
um yeah
and actually invest in you know the
educational system that built this
country and that raised our parents and
our grandparents
um
yeah
yeah anything from you tony let me go
ahead and switch this screen there we go
that's better um
so uh one thing i always ask anyone
who's running for office is i have just
just but one goal in in my meager life
and
it's to tax the church will you help me
tax the church
[Laughter]
you can't go one show without asking
that question can you i will never go a
show without asking that question tax in
the church i have i'm not going to lie
to you like that's one thing i've always
promised mom wasn't being honest i have
not had a single conversation about tax
in the church
i
haven't had a single conversation about
it um
but if you want we'll have a
conversation after this about your
opinions on it
okay
okay noted
dually noted well let me let me let me
ask a brief question about that so do
you think that it is ethical
i think i know the answer to this
question so i'll change a little bit do
you think that it would be appropriate
not ethic because we know that it's
unethical to take in funds
from donations and use them to buy your
seventh jet right i think everybody can
agree
on that but do you think that there's
like a threshold where you know
churches should be held accountable for
the amount of
of
you know tax-free um contributions that
they get from their parishioners that
need to go back out into the
into the public or into the the
community in order for them to maintain
some some level of tax exemption status
yeah i think it's absolutely fair and
reasonable yeah
okay cool
um
so uh we talked we talked a little bit
about uh you touched briefly on health
care but i'd like to hear kind of like
what is your what would be your plan ray
you know what what or
before we get there what what do you
envision as far as
uh universal healthcare medicare for all
whatever name that we want to throw on
that you know do you have a particular
uh
one of the styles of universal health
care that you favor the most that you
think would be the most effective
um and
after that how do you what would be the
best way to transition to it
yeah so
you can
take medicare
give it to everybody
the end every everybody everybody gets
taken care of but um
realistically uh obamacare the
affordable care act laid the groundwork
for universal healthcare uh in this
country so in congress i wanna you know
build on that and put america back on
track to universal health care uh for
the tax cut that anne wagner voted for
in 2017 we could have
we could have uh taken care of uh
medicare for all the next five years um
and saved countless lives um
so absolutely i want to i will support
medicare for all
um
and just getting their contract like
people shouldn't be going to the
hospital with decisions shouldn't be
making a decision on glenn's hospital um
based on whether or not they'll go broke
i don't think that's
fair or uh just in any wealthy society
is this
do you think the messaging on it has
been bad from the medic from the
democratic party or like what's that
what's the whole i mean that that
question the answer can obviously be yes
but you know what where's the messaging
going wrong how can you help fix it
yeah i think
voters aren't hearing it enough how
they're going to hear how they're going
to see it in their day-to-day lives
there's not enough counter on the
republicans
because republicans have this uh
strategy of
hey if we kick enough gears in the sand
um
things don't get done we don't know why
things don't get done you know things
aren't getting done
um
and they'll do everything they can to
divide folks on issues so that if we're
giving this person health care we're
taking away this from you um
right so there's got to be some pushback
uh on republicans i'm just calling them
out on their [ __ ]
so
what would you say is the most um
common objection to it that you hear
from people who are at least trying to
be reasonable because we know the
unreasonable idiots right like the not
worried about their arguments but
what would you say is is that argument
and and how do you
engage in the conversation with that
person to help them
you know kind of see the light so to
speak
um probably that i'll lose my health
care or i'll lose my doctor
that's probably that's that's been a big
one i've been hearing um
but i wouldn't support any health care
plan uh i'm coming from a family of
union workers so if you're a union
worker
and you fought hard for a good contract
i think you'd be able to keep that good
contract uh keep that keep your health
care that you fought for under that good
contract
um
i think you should be able to opt in and
opt out
as you please
but um there are plenty of folks here in
st louis to go
through their
through 20 30 years of life without
coverage um
never go never go to a hospital and it'd
be fatal in a lot of issues a lot of
situations
so it sounds like you're kind of for a a
public option rather than not than just
single-payer only right is that is that
kind of how you feel
yeah
okay can you just explain to me why you
think that would work better
um
i can't say what will work better until
you know we actually see these things
but in uh
that's true yeah that's fair but
um but what would be like
so so here's here's where i would kind
of
counter punch that a little bit is i
think that if you have competition from
the private sector they're going to all
gang up on the public option and try to
choke it out
you know and and and then you'll end up
having people who are going to say well
i'm paying for my own health care and
i'm paying for everyone else's health
care who takes the public option so
that could create some
in addition to the existing negative
animosity towards that well all
animosity is negative um you know there
you would add some existing um
irritation from from people and
who are going to argue that they're
paying for poor people's health care but
also paying for their own premium plan
you know so like to me
i would say i think that we need to
eliminate
all of the
uh
private companies the private insurance
companies at least and just
conglomerate all of those people who now
have private insurance under one
insurance company leave the doctors
public at least for
um
for
for i'm sorry the doctors private at
least for now
um and for the foreseeable future and
that way everybody has is paying into
the same pot everybody has the same
deductible everybody has the same you
know amount that's taken out in tax
obviously except for you know as you
make more you obviously will pay a
little bit more into that
but i i think that you get a little bit
less
i don't i think you get less pushback to
the policy your way i certainly agree
with that
and it might be the way to go
but i think that effectively once it
once we have it in place
that it will work better if you didn't
have that competition if that makes any
sense
can i jump in here ditch
no
okay get it in
mikey might dunk on me and banned me for
life um but um so ray
yeah
let me ask you ray so your opponent wha
what how did they vote on abolishing
health care for average working
americans what's their record on voting
uh to get rid of obamacare to get rid of
the aca make sure americans don't have
health care what was their record
uh
i don't know the exact number but i know
every time it's come up she's voted to
uh to abolish it get ready get rid of
their health care that's that's that's
what you say you know uh democrats you
know we talked earlier about democrats
having a shitty message and this is this
is the stuff that we do what we do is we
like a line item this [ __ ] before we
govern because i believe politics and
government are two separate things i
know you know that ray um jay nixon is a
democrat who won in missouri twice um a
lot a lot a lot of people call him a
dino you know democrat name only you
know but but the guy but the guy has a
lot of liberal views um and he's still
one in the state because i think there's
one thing jane nixon understands and he
understands that politics and government
are two separate things
jay nixon is no dummy uh you know he had
some trouble there at the end with
ferguson but you know every every
politician is gonna have their their
their little trials here but here's the
thing is that we all we always fight
about line items right we're always
saying line item this line at them that
we got to change this we got to change
that we got to govern like this we got a
government like that well we don't get
to govern if ray doesn't get to
washington like ray can do whatever the
hell he wants he can think whatever the
hell he wants he can tell dutch whatever
the hell he wants to tell him but if rey
doesn't get the washington if ray
doesn't run a campaign where this guy
can be missouri's second the democrat
missouri second forget about a line item
forget about the aca forget about public
option i mean ray doesn't have the the
ability to say anything about a public
option i mean as much as he has right
here on the show until we get him on the
floor of the house as soon as we get him
on the floor of the house he can debate
and go back and forth and we can
pressure him and we can make sure that
ray does exactly what we want him to do
once he's in that seat and i think
democrats miss that sometimes democrats
liberals anybody in the democratic
coalition they miss this they miss this
messaging thing republicans get it these
fascists have got it for for decades
they get it decades and decades and
decades because they know they know that
politics and government are two separate
things they know it they know it they've
always operated that way and we we we
fall on our messaging so my advice to
ray is
because i'm a messaging guy so my advice
to ray is to go out there and say hey do
you know do you know that the the person
i'm running against voted for you not to
have health care not only that they were
campaigning against against the state of
missouri to expand medicaid
not only not only does she not like you
to have health care she voted against
you having health care i'm for you
having health care and i'll go fight for
you to have health care vote for me i'll
go do something about health care
whatever the hell that is i'll go do
some i'll do a hell of a lot more than
what she's going to do what she's going
to do she's
she he whoever the hell it is they're
they're gonna try to take it away from
you they don't want you to have health
care so i think i think democrats in the
democratic coalition miss it
and that's and that's that's the thing
that the democrats love to do is they
love to
let's tear him apart first
and then put his uh withered bones up
there and then run him against the
problem like god [ __ ] damn we lost
again he's like no you don't get him in
power and then try to influence him you
just say i'll just destroy all of the
candidates and then the corporates are
just like we got one in the chamber
let's fire this guy off and he'll win
automatically because you know what i
mean it's like we were we're kind of our
own
peril when it comes to candidates if we
don't even support any of them in the
first place like they never get the
support they only get the criticism and
then they wonder why they lose all the
time
right that raises a really good point um
which is sort of tangential to this
right how much support if any and
communication have you had with and if
any with the the local democratic party
your
your precinct captains that sort of
stuff um as far as like endorsements and
sponsorships and any support at all from
the dncc
um
from the
i'm sorry
yeah so i work for the state party so i
like i knew i have relationships and do
all the chairs and presidents and local
parties um so of course they've all
invited me to come see their local
democratic clubs and the union clubs and
i'm just coming one time i'm going to
make sure i keep coming back and back
and back to make make sure that they
know i'm a serious candidate i'm serious
about winning this district um
but the thing is i'm starting to see
that they're really excited about
someone young
the number one thing i hate hearing in
missouri is that missouri democrats
don't have a bench we have no one coming
up it's not just me that's coming up
there's a plethora of young kids who are
energized who are excited to fight for
something here in missouri
there's no democrats that live in
missouri you kidding me ray
yeah
well that that's that's that's the old
thing of your red state there's no no
one blew here you know and and again and
again we we do this we do this to
ourselves and when i say we i don't mean
like like
card-carrying democrats i mean liberals
independents moderates people who don't
want to vote for republicans anymore
because they i don't know they tried to
commit a coup they tried to overturn our
our government they tried to [ __ ] on the
constitution right just a little thing
like that that's right right so so i
mean
my my message always is is that look you
don't need some fancy thing where you
got to go
you got to go sell the bill that you're
going to get when you get to congress
like
they never do that like they they
they're like abortion abortion abortion
abortion and more abortion like that's
that's their message is to scare oh if
you if you vote for democrats oh my god
there's going to be so many dead babies
they'll be in the gutters in the streets
you know that that that's their thing
right that they all don't take away your
guns which there hasn't been one goddamn
democrat in in this country that's
taking away guns you elect fascists and
you see who's going to take away guns
reagan's the one who took away guns well
you know for the most part yeah well i
mean i mean he he he he was the backer
of the 1992
uh uh
uh
gun ban the assault right yeah yeah well
yeah and the handgun ban so i'm and well
rightfully so he got shot by a handgun
but i guess the point is is that if if i
you know i forgot about that
yeah
yeah yeah i forgot he got shot yeah by
somebody who wanted to impress jodie
foster yeah that [ __ ] is running
free too that's weird but you know it
happens we we live in weird timelines
these days what was this that hinckley
right yep they they released that i
think yeah i was in my house but
white
[Laughter]
oh yeah mike mikey's got it mikey's
gotta be yeah
i wish i could shoot at a president hit
the president and then at any point in
my timeline after expect to be walking
on a sidewalk oh it gets better than
that mikey that guy that guy for years
and years because he was he was deemed
uh you know not fit to serve trial and
they found him criminally insane all
that [ __ ] and he he would he would get
released from the mental hospital and he
would spend you know weeks and weeks
with his mother mother under supervision
stuff for years like that guy wasn't
locked away in a in a prison cell or
something that guy was locked away in an
institution he would come in and out in
and out um for years and years and years
so it gets much worse than what you're
saying you know they would they would
have electric chaired my dead body for
oh
well
let's let's be real if they're if there
was if the person holding the gun that
shot reagan had the skin color of you a
ray they'd have killed him right there
on the sidewalk
yeah
hell you wouldn't know what you wouldn't
have walked on a sidewalk in the prison
either no because
right yeah bad walks of heaven
i mean if you want to be honest about it
that that's a very good segue actually
to the ques one of the questions i want
to ask ray so one of the things that i
think that i would imagine that you're
getting a lot from from you know the joe
schmoe in the middle out there is what's
your stance on
this whole defunded police thing are you
going to destroy our police departments
are are we going to have chaos in the
streets you know what where
how do you address that question and um
you know
sort of
uh calm them down from their belief that
we're going to
have no more law enforcement in this
country yeah um
so i guess all preface was saying um
i already said uh i'm right next to
corey bush corey's got the city i've got
the suburbs here um and part of the way
they won last time in 2020 was anne
wagner ran ad after ad after ad by
saying democrats are gonna bring
uh antifa into your suburbs and you mean
you mean do you mean she used fear she
used fear
no astonishing
yeah so we expect her to
you know have even worse uh dog whistle
politics with me um
same racist tropes that she that she's
used before
um
but
yeah it's pretty much
we care i know i understand that the
relationship between the police and the
suburbs uh folks in the suburbs have
their police um i don't want to you know
completely disband police departments we
obviously need our police to keep us
safe um but a police officer doesn't
always need to be coming out on a call
it sometimes needs to be a resource
officer or someone who can help with
whatever the situation is we should
definitely rethink of rethink how we um
how we spend money on our police uh
departments there's no reason for tanks
to be rolling down the streets in the
suburbs of saint louis missouri that's
absurd
yeah and i think one of the things that
democrats miss a lot on this is when we
have that this conversation with our
friends on the right
is that when you call the police you're
literally calling a gun to the situation
so sometimes you have to kind of think
okay would a gun make this situation
better
and i think generally the answer that
question has to be no
you know but but but people don't always
think about it that way they think about
it as i'm calling as like in the karen
mentality i'm calling the person that's
gonna you know give me the upper hand
over you
and that's where
the the problems arise but you're
exactly right you know cops don't need
to be called to get cast out of trees
neither is the fire department for that
[ __ ] matter so you know it's they
don't need to be called to break up
domestic disputes unless there's a
reason that for that particular domestic
dispute you know to be broken up by a
gun it that absolutely might happen but
just generally speaking if if doug and
amy are fighting in the kitchen
that that doesn't always necessarily
mean that uh you know you need to call a
gun into that are you talking about fist
fighting or arguing i i'm well i'm using
the word fighting as a proxy for arguing
so
you know what i was clarifying yeah
people for so so people call like
neighbors call the police especially in
apartment environments they call the
police a lot for for yelling and you
know sometimes i get it like they're
annoyed by the yelling and you know
maybe they're worried and sometimes
people do it in good faith but other
times they don't you know and it's and
it's like so am i
if you were going to call someone you
end up calling out someone who's
qualified to de-escalate that situation
then that is a good thing but
unfortunately we have seen over and over
the police are not particularly good at
de-escalating situations just their
presence and the presence of their badge
and their guns sometimes can do the have
the opposite effect and that's sometimes
a no fault of their own just by their
presence
it it it escalates the situation you
know because people know what can happen
so your thoughts on that so let me ask
you ray would you would you give more
funding to police in tactical gear or
training
training like you can never have
training um
with firearms period but absolutely
training
so so so you're saying what you're
saying is you don't want to defund the
police you want to make sure to fund
them for training because i i haven't
heard one democrat that either is in
office or running for a major office
that has said that they absolutely want
to abolish the police there's a lot of
people saying it out there but i don't
think there's been a
someone that has policy that that has to
do with actually making policy and
and uh legislating policy that it said
we want to defund and completely abolish
um but i think i think that the the
the other problem that we have with the
democratic party or the democratic
coalition is um they they get these
these catch phrases like uh defund the
police and not the the right turns it
around and and they don't get ahead of
the messaging right medicare for all
defunct police
universal universal pre-k is another one
i've been i've been yelling this into a
microphone for months that they
shouldn't they should stop saying the
words universal at all like stop saying
it it's it's a bad word to the to white
people hate the word universal stop
saying it you know what you say
studios right exactly that's it that's
it what you say is is we're gonna kids
are gonna start school at three instead
of five
kids are gonna start school at three
instead of five tell them what the hell
it is tell them what the hell it is and
and so so um that defund the police
thing i i think it it's not a it's not a
thing where you know the the the rights
thinking or anyone's really thinking
that democrats are gonna abolish the
police department right but it really is
about it really is about changing the
focus of the budgets um and where that
money is allocated to training as
opposed to tactical gear i mean i would
much rather the officers that show up
on a scene where there's a dangerous
situation have [ __ ] training to
de-escalate that situation than to roll
in with a [ __ ] half million dollar
tank right i'd rather have him him and
the two guys two gals that show up in
uniform to have a half a million dollars
worth of education i'd re held a lot
better than having them have a half
million dollar tank i'm just saying
yeah and and on the defund the police i
i just gotta throw this in there the
person who wanted to defund the police
the person who's voted to defund the
police is yeah and whitner in 2020 that
heroes actually voted against it and she
voted
the american uh president biden's uh
stimulus
which sent money to local and state
governments which teams are police she's
that's that's what you do
you say she wants to defund the police
here's the record here's the record
right here baby so that's that's the
messaging right so that's what democrats
have to do like ray or anyone else out
there running in these districts hey
you're an incumbent or not like you you
got you got it you got to go after them
you got to be if you're going to get in
a boxing ring to play politics put the
[ __ ] gloves on and get in the ring
and start boxing right why do we tie our
one hand behind our back why ray why
would you not want to call out her or
whoever whoever whoever it is that is
your opponent
on their record of defunding the police
which they're like oh he wants to defund
the police like no i i mean i don't but
you actually did you voted for it like i
i would have signs everywhere that says
this person wants to defund the police
like everywhere bumper stickers
everywhere
you don't want to know who wants to
defund the police in the suburbs here
they are here's the voting record here's
what they go after him straight go after
him we we got it we got to stop we
as a democratic coalition
we have to stop being so scared
so terrified of saying the wrong thing
[ __ ] that [ __ ] just go after him we
we're we're not gonna be able to change
what i was talking about the half
million dollar budget for the tank or
the education we're not gonna change it
if rey doesn't go to washington
she ain't gonna do it is she no hell no
she ain't but rape ray might rape we got
a hell of a lot better chance with ray
on the floor of the house than we do
with her that's all i'm saying
that's absolutely true
mikey you're eerily quiet change that
what do you got
i asked my questions when you were gone
yeah you skipped out on them i was gone
for like they were really intuitive too
like this for like a minute
no it was like three when it might be
didn't you have a timer you're gone
mikey rebels he revels in every every
time i have stepped away from the show
over the la the year that we've been
doing this show and by the way we've
just passed our one-year anniversary so
have congratulations
where's my gift
yeah anniversary it was actually like
about
10 days ago or something but you know we
didn't we didn't celebrate it you know
we just
we just gave each other
you know don't you say nothing across
the room i'm about to say i know you
love nasty mind the bedroom guys
we do have some questions from the chat
uh tim from supervisor question uh
student debt crisis
this is my favorite topic um for obvious
reasons um
i still have student loans my friends
have student loans folks all over my
district have federal student loans um
and again for the cost of that tax cut
in 2017 that my opponent ann wagner
voted for we could have forgiven every
single federal student loan in the
country but she decided that a tax cut
for the wealthiest billionaires on wall
street was more important than
a family of being able to start a
business
buy a house
have a baby buy a car move on with their
lives um
and making an investment and taking a 50
000 burden off someone's back is going
to give you a greater return on
investment than the tax cut in 2017 had
um
i just
can't uh get over um
forgiving student loans and i absolutely
want to do it in 2023 when
reconciliation comes up i'll be on the
floor of the house um fighting for it
until we pass it
you know i think the other thing that
people forget about with that is that
when you have a lot of people who will
come up and say well i paid for
for you know like my dad will say that i
paid for all my college your college
costs twenty five hundred dollars right
like calm down
yeah calm down would you i paid for my
degree you paid 38 cents an annihilator
and it was purple
like you didn't pay a lot you weren't
gonna eat that purple now later anyway
right did you say and in the middle is
now in later come on now dutch
now and later not late are are you
really uh tone policing me or grammar
policing me on the word and okay i'm
grammar policing you're now racist
is that what you call them laughing
taffys yes actually laughing taffys
big league chews
big biggest largely
largely chews yes
okay so um i'll tell you what let's do
one more uh policy question for rey
that's who we've talked what haven't we
touched on here
um oh there we go
campaign finance reform one of our
favorites
um
go
and and in one sense we're gonna
overturn citizens united um it was the
worst court case since since dred scott
absolutely uh terrible it's corruption
in washington um can i just piggyback
off that uh on the other on the other
side um
we absolutely absolutely have to
um ban
every single member of congress and
their senior staff
that's a bigger part of this we have to
ban their senior staff also from being
able to trade stocks um members of
congress obviously are privy to
information and if they're trading
stocks it's essentially day trading
and a lot of times your senior staff
members know just as much just as much
if not more than the member actually
does um
so i just want to throw that out there
and and ann is your opponent right and
then her name
yeah yeah what's up what's what's ann
wagner's record on campaign finance
reform it loves it she's made millions
of dollars uh yeah
she's made a lot more money than i have
um so let me let me ask you how does
that affect missouri's second what what
would you tell if i was a someone in
missouri second i said ray you know anne
does this and does that wha what makes
you different on campaign finance reform
than her what what are you what are you
gonna tell me
um i'm pretty much clear on uh i think
we need to get dark money out of
politics when people donate i'm not
accepting first of all a dime of
corporate pac money um i'm not accepting
any money from wall street i'm not
accepting any money from the big
agricultural corporations i'm not
accepting any money from the oil
industry
um
and i think that's kind of just the
ethical thing to do at this point um
but congressman ann wagner she gets all
our money from wall street um she's
never here in the district she's not
here right now in the district and i'm
here right now um
wait you mean you mean she's she's a
she's a corporate sludge fund is that
what you're saying you're saying you're
saying what she does is she takes money
from all them big huge
scary businesses that really go into
these these suburbs of st louis and
really you know hurt the working-class
people she does that oh my gosh
from all those evil corporations that
are enforcing mass mandates on you right
now right well you see you see what i'm
getting at you see what i'm getting at
see see the messaging and that that
happens is you you know you can you can
take instead of saying well um you know
uh i i uh i don't want to take oil money
and this and that you can just turn it
around on them that's what they do
that's that's what she's gonna do she's
gonna say oh ray ray reid he's a
socialist he's a socialist and he does
this and he does that and he takes all
that socialist money and he's gonna he's
gonna press all that socialism on you
that's hold on we know that rey is ra
you got your check from george soros
right
well i wish i had all right
ours is coming any
day all right i i got mine in the
mailbox today what are you guys doing
you guys are doing it wrong we know we
trust that it's coming
you have to have gotten yours
i'm still waiting on my oprah money too
[Laughter]
but you get what i'm saying about the
messaging with the campaign finance
reform right it's the same it's the same
thing as defund the police uh you know
uh democrats are always
the first ones to get out and say how
how they're gonna be great and this is
gonna be fantastic and it's all gonna be
fuzzy and warm and republicans are like
socialist socialist socialist and
they're like oh my god it's ray reid
he's so scary he's a socialist well if
you get out there and you you paint them
the way that you want to paint them and
i don't just mean ray i mean any
democrat for that matter but if rey gets
out there and paints and the way that
she needs to be painted with the record
that she has because you're not lying
you're telling a record you're saying
hey this person is taking corporate
dollars from big business that you don't
like that you say is scary why would you
vote for her i'm not doing that why
would you vote for her right so i mean
you need how many 200 200 votes 200
votes yeah exactly right exactly exactly
i i bet i could flip 300 people in in 10
minutes with with a message like that oh
yeah
yeah
there was one last thing that i forgot
that i did want to ask you about so
there it looks like they're trying to
gerrymander uh missouri a little bit to
try to make it so that
you're gonna have i think you guys have
eight districts if i remember correctly
and they're gonna try to get it so that
it's
uh seven republican districts and i you
sent out a tweet on that uh what what
was that tell us the statistics of your
tweet again if you if you recall what
that was
um from a couple of days ago as far as
the percentage of democrats in um
uh missouri compared to the amount of
representation that democrats would have
because that was pretty astonishing
i don't remember the exact number i
remember it was more than uh
50 though um
republican
i remember exactly what it was so it was
yes because because i i talked about
that
five minutes before i saw your tweet on
a space and when i saw your
when i saw your tweet i put in the space
and i don't expect you remember exactly
the numbers but the exactly the numbers
were something like
um
47 or something percent of voters in
missouri
overall voted for the republican party
for the democratic party but yeah the
dem the republican party
wants 80
70 88
of the total
uh members of congress and the and
ultimately what will end up being the
electoral votes
within uh
within that state so that's
the way that you phrase that was perfect
because it goes to show that they don't
give a [ __ ] about you everything that
the republicans are doing all the way
from the elect and the electoral college
is not the republicans fault i'm not
saying it's their fault because it
predates their party however
they use it
far better than we do they're democrats
absolutely gerrymander they just don't
gerrymander as good as republicans do
they just don't gerrymander as
consistently as republicans do they
don't i mean you you have republicans
who literally are advocating their
candidates right now people just like
you who are quote unquote grassroots uh
republicans who by the way it's weird a
lot of them are anti-pac now too but the
but they're actually they actually want
to change the constitution of the united
states to have it be so that every
county
counts for their the electoral votes of
that county that would sway the election
to about a 70 percent
uh republican win no matter what because
you have a county with one person it's
worth the same as a county with a
million people that makes no sense
whatsoever and that but that's literally
what they're trying to get pushed
through now will it pass
highly unlikely but you see where the
end game is at there right and it's
whatever they can do
to
to cheat and keep conservative politics
at the forefront where what you're
literally trying to do and i think this
is a big part of your messaging too
brother is
you're literally fighting for votes for
people who aren't going to vote for you
right like that's how much
typically we care on our side of the
aisle is we fight just as hard for the
vote
of the guy that's going to vote against
us as we do for the people who are going
to vote for us because that is democracy
not this crap that we see
out there and
the last little
ranting that i have is isn't it amazing
that
and i believe i saw some things that
that anne wagner was tweeting about
mandates but isn't it amazing that the
republican um talking points have
shifted
from two years ago when all we heard
about was
we don't want to have universal health
care because i'm gonna lose my doctor
and now
doctors are part of an evil
cabal that are pushing vaccines on us
and trying to control the masses and we
don't trust doctors and pharmacists
anymore isn't it amazing how that
transitions so quickly so you know what
they don't get to use that excuse about
you know i don't want to lose my doctor
anymore unless they are actively going
out and combating those tweets and those
facebook posts uh that are on social
media which i guarantee they're not
doing because they don't want to get
defriended by their buddies so
there's my rant so ray how did ray how
do you use that how do you use that that
that anne wagner is a cueing on her
how to use it oh i'm actually like kind
of exploiting that because she does this
dance uh because the shape of this
district she does this dance between the
the tea party side the marjorie taylor
greens and lauren boberts of the
republican party and the liz cheney
of the republican party so in the
suburbs she'll you know kind of align
herself with whatever liz cheney's
saying and in the more rural areas of
the district she'll align herself with
whatever crazy [ __ ] marjorie taylor
green is cooking up um
so she's she's trying to glenn yunk in
that damn thing is that what you're
saying pretty much yeah yeah that's
republicans in a nutshell
all right so uh
so
i know so we're at the end of the hour
um
let's hear about rey's campaign uh mikey
if you will
tell us
yeah where yeah that ray not the other
array uh
where can people find you where can
people people support you you do not
have a tiny little district
um like some folks who are doing
grassroots do you have a district that
you need gas money to get through so
how can we support that um where can we
find you on socials
i am at ray reid r-e-e-d-m-o
on everything facebook twitter instagram
and tick-tock and you can find links to
donate to our campaign in the bios of
all of them um
yeah we're taking grass grassroots money
so
feel free chip in ten dollars or really
whatever you can um to help us win this
win this thing
perfect uh we'll we'll get some twitter
spaces going with you and a couple of
the other guys in that group that we're
in uh
pretty soon try to get you some more
exposure so
um all right well what the mikey uh
would you like to ask for some money as
well before we uh play the music again
um
sure
hi guys it's me your old buddy mikey
famine
look [ __ ] i know you got that [ __ ]
w-2 three weeks ago now and i know you
got your [ __ ] tax return i quit
[ __ ] playing with my goddamn money i
know you got paid you already went to h
r block you already got that [ __ ] you
already lost 300 because you needed it
that day you got a little bit left
we're gonna need that
so
if you can by all means go to
page
dig on www.patreon.com
and let us get a little piece of the pie
so we can be like george and wheezy
dutch is very expensive
we have to continually replace
microphones and monitors
and headphones because he gets in a rage
and co-hosts
yeah and he he likes to stream uh
minecraft when he's not doing this kind
of stuff and roblox and he gets very
angry when the creepers get him and he
breaks [ __ ] it's getting expensive and
you know what you guys are going to pay
for it now because me and haas are done
we're done buying monitors for dusk
because he's put these tiny little truck
hand fists right through the screen
so
again guys if you could just help us
replace some of this broken equipment
because of dutch's rage because he
streams little kid games patreon.com
dig on america
and by little kid games he means redtube
in your hands going through the screen
calm down jerky boy
all right so folks uh there it is that
is the show uh for the first hour uh we
will see you for the second half of the
show in
30 seconds
aha